dimanche matin dans ce kiosque à
journaux de téhéran des résidants
observe l'histoire à la une celle de
masse un ami ni et quelques heures plus
tôt la colère étaient palpables sur les
réseaux sociaux et dans la rue ces
femmes ont manifesté en retirant leurs
voix
massa à mini avait seulement 22 ans elle
était en visite à téhéran mardi avec sa
famille quand elle a été arrêtée par la
police des moeurs jeudi les auteurs
étaient confirme qu'elle aurait eu un
malaise cardiaque
elle est morte vendredi à l'hôpital
après avoir passé trois jours dans le
coma le manifestant crois qu'elle a été
battue mais le ministre de l'intérieur a
déclaré que massa avait des ennuis de
santé turow faute kadyrov tamda lol nous
devons attendre les résultats d'examen
concernant les causes de sa mort le top
6 n'a pas encore été fait alors nous ne
pouvons pas commencer
la police de téhéran maintient qu'il n'y
a eu aucun contact physique entre les
agents et la jeune femme mais l affaire
survient alors que bien des femmes
dénoncent cette police responsable entre
autres de faire respecter le port du
voile obligatoire
je trouve que le gouvernement devrait
retirer l'obligation de porter le hidjab
celles qui ne veulent pas le porter ne
devraient pas être obligés de le faire
n'ont pas créé autant de peur et de
crainte au sein de la population
explique t-elle
en soirée le président iranien ebrahim
raïssi s'est entretenu avec la famille
il a ordonné la tenue d'une enquête
il si mélissa françois radio canada
montréal